are the triangles shown below congruent
similar or neither so for two triangles
to be congruent they have to have the
same size and shape or another way to
think about it is if you were to rotate
or flip one shape could you make it
coincide with the other or another way
to think about congruent is especially
in the case of triangles is all of the
corresponding sides and angles have to
be the same so right over here we see
one side on this shorter on the smaller
triangle is five here it's 7.5 actually
all of these sides here are 5 all of
these sides are 7.5 so clearly these two
triangles do not have the same side
lengths so it is not congruent and
actually you can figure that out just by
looking at them that they are not the
same size that this is a larger triangle
than this one over here so they cannot
be congruent similarity on the other
hand two triangles can be similar even
if they are different sizes as long as
they are the same shape and when we talk
about the same shape there's two ways to
think about it one is is that the ratio
between corresponding side lengths are
the same or that all of the
corresponding angles are congruent to
each other so we could look and this
right over here this little mark says
that this angle is equal to this angle
is equal to this angle and we know that
the sum of the angles in a triangle have
to add up to 80 if these 3 I start had
to have to add up to 180 and these 3 are
all the same three things adding up to
180 each of them have to be 60 degrees
but that's also going on over here this
angle is equal to this angle is equal to
this angle they all have to be they all
have to be 60 degrees so for these two
triangles all of the corresponding
angles are the same and in fact all of
the angles are the same so because of
that we can say that it is similar
another way to think about it is that
the ratio of corresponding sides is the
same so if we say that this side j/k
corresponds to side zy and here we can
kind of take our pick because all the
sides have the same length we say the
ratio between these two sides so JK over
z
over Z y is equal to five over seven
point five and that's the same ratio as
KL as KL over Y X so that is equal to KL
over Y X which is five over seven point
five and that that's also the same ratio
as JL over ZX that's the same as JL over
ZX so two ways to think about it you
could say hey look all of the
corresponding angles are the same and
you actually only have to look at two of
the angles because if two of them are
the same the third one's going to be the
same all of the corresponding angles are
the same that by itself tells you it's
sorry that by itself tells you it is
similar and on top of that another way
to think about it is the ratio between
corresponding sides are the same so this
is a simply two triangles are similar
now one thing I want you to realize a
congruent triangle is a little bit more
strict it's kind of a similar triangle
where all of the sides are also the same
length really all of the corresponding
features are the same size so all
congruent triangles if something is if
two triangles are congruent they are
definitely going to be similar if two
triangles are similar they might be
congruent but not necessarily I guess
one way to think about it if you think
about the universe of similar triangles
if you think about the universe of
similar triangles congruent triangles
are a subset of that so everything
that's congruent is similar to triangles
are congruent to each other they're
going to be similar to each other but
two triangles that are similar to each
other may or may not be congruent